إنه نوع الزيارة التي تأتي مرة واحدة
في العمر
، ولا أعتقد أن الأمر المثير هو
الكلمة الصحيحة التي تعرفها لوصف الشعور الذي قمت
بزيارته إلى روما ، لكن هنا جو مختلف تمامًا ،
هذه الزيارة هي
تاريخ في
صنع المليون كاثوليكي  مجتمع في
بلد به 200 جنسية مختلفة
يمارسون مجموعة متنوعة من الأديان
، سيصبح البابا فرانسيس أول بابا يقول
قداسًا في شبه الجزيرة العربية ، وهي منطقة ذات
أغلبية ساحقة من المسلمين الأسقف بول
الذي يعيش في الشرق الأوسط منذ
أكثر من عقد يقول تنوع
الكاثوليك  المجتمع هنا هو ما يجعله
مميزًا للغاية
، فالأغلبية هم بالتأكيد هنود وفلبينيين ،
لكن لدينا أسئلة من
البلدان الناطقة باللغة العربية ،
تم تخصيص تذاكر القداس البابوي من
خلال نظام يانصيب مع
حاملي التذاكر رسميًا في يوم عطلة
العمل والإثارة واضحة عندما
أنت تتحدث إلى رواد الكنيسة هنا في أبو
ظبي ، نريد راحة اليد حتى أولئك الذين
يعملون قالوا لي أننا
سنهزم  من أجل وظيفتنا لمجرد أن نكون
هنا وأن نكون مع البابا ، إنه حلم
أن يأتي البابا إلى هنا ، ومن
المدهش كيف يتحقق الحلم أن
يأتي البابا هو صورة لكل مسيحي
إنه فرح todos de nada
Muslim  البلد الذي يمكنه أن يفعل أي شيء أفضل
من هذا ، من المتوقع أن يجذب الجمهور العام
مائة وخمسة وثلاثين
ألفًا من المؤمنين وفقًا
للمنظمين ، سيكون الشماس الأمريكي دونالد
فوكس من بين أولئك الذين يساعدون البابا
فرانسيس في اليوم الذي سأضطر فيه بالتأكيد
إلى محاولة ضمان ذلك  لا
أُظهر توتري ، سيكون بالتأكيد
أكبر نوع احتفال أقوم
به على الإطلاق ، هناك شعور
بالتأثير الحقيقي في بلد
يروج بوعي شديد لصورة
التسامح الباكستاني الذي يعرف فيصل كيران
أنه عاش في الإمارات العربية المتحدة من أجل  ما يقرب من ثمانية
كاد ، وقد شاهدها البابا شخصيًا في السابق
يصف ما تعنيه هذه الزيارة
بالنسبة له أنه قادم إلى منزلي ، يبدو الأمر كما
لو أن المسيح قادم إلى منزلي وهو شعور
[موسيقى]
يتقاسمه العديد من أعضاء ما
هو  هذا المجتمع المترابط بيكي
أندرسون سي إن إن أبو ظبي